Wow you made this some girl gave that to
me to give to them then they canceled
the show yeah I know somebody took tours
with them with the fans homes
her name is Vienna she's helping us out
that's not your real name now you guys
just keep multiplying
you with them what here at the bansuri
Hey
how do you get accepted you're invited
every time I see I just pulled in my
stinger
I don't think you should get next with
him you understand you know we're almost
broke right yeah I heard some mineral
guy has all your money things are gonna
change around here yeah
[Music]
we have to behave like a band of how
he's supposed to travel only 500 miles
four days I say we talk to my wolf my
big bad wolf
[Music]
a lot of people here what you out she
has to go hard I work
keep this stand on its feet you know
what I have to do I got a crazy kid on
my hands
you messed him up I get better lock your
doors tonight
the bevels out
how do you do it
better survive this place
you
you